[Music]
on this friday night
pushing for answers into the wii charity
affair
with the liberals stall tactics and why
the conservatives are demanding a second
separate investigation canada's new
multi-million dollar deal with a chinese
government-owned firm
the contract with the company dubbed the
huawei of airport security
as america's coveted 19 cases climb
tensions escalate
her decision to undermine economic
growth
is devastating why georgia's governor is
suing atlanta's mayor
and that's captain sir tom moore to you
now
it really was truly outstanding
england's national treasure
gets nicer
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
sonia diol good evening and thanks very
much for joining us well there's a new
development tonight
in the wii charity controversy that is
plaguing the liberal government
the house ethics committee has managed
to stall a vote
until next week on an opposition motion
to investigate prime minister trudeau's
family ties to the organization
the meeting lasted nearly four hours and
included lengthy speeches
liberal mp greg fergus at times even
speaking
in latin and he didn't end there
democracy is fragile we take a look at
the
you know 5 000 years of reliable human
history
oral and and written history that we can
we can turn to well the meeting comes
after the federal ethics commissioner
signaled he will be investigating
trudeau as well as finance minister bill
morneau for failing to recuse themselves
from talks about the we deal abigail
beeman is following the latest
developments for us abigail
sonja the ethics commissioner is already
investigating the prime minister and the
finance minister
now conservatives are calling for the
lobbying commissioner
to look at whether we charity should
have registered with the government
this comes after senior bureaucrat
rachel wernick testified about
communications
she had with we founder craig kielberger
the office of the lobbying commissioner
tells global news she has received the
letter from the conservatives but they
don't comment as to whether
investigations are underway
the conservatives and the ndp are
pushing for the ethics committee to
investigate as well
the liberals pushed back saying it
wasn't the committee's job
and it should be left to the ethics
commissioner it's called a fishing trip
we're going out and we wanted to see
know what we can find
we shouldn't do that we have
a commissioner of ethics well it raises
the question whether or not there was
attempt to buy political influence
that to me is the issue before us it's a
problem when taxpayer dollars
are going out of their hand
and then into the hand of the mother of
a public officeholder
i'll tell you the only member of the
trudeau family that i want to see at
this committee is justin
we also heard from finance minister bill
morneau for the first time since the
ethics commissioner announced he would
be under investigation as well
morneau apologized for not recusing
himself from we discussions
but he wouldn't answer questions about
whether his office was in contact with
we
before the summer grant announcement
this after wernick testified it was
finance officials who first floated the
idea of speaking with we
what we heard yesterday from the
officials was that
they were working to make sure that they
could find a way to create the policy
and to deliver on behalf of students
i think departments were working
together i don't have any
direct ability to answer that question
morneau was also asked about any cabinet
discussions about his or the prime
minister's potential
conflicts before the decision he said he
couldn't speak to cabinet discussions
on the question of waiving cabinet
confidence the prime minister said this
week they are still looking at quote
what
further openness they can show sonya
abigail beeman in oshawa thank you very
much abigail
well controversy tonight surrounding a
decision by the federal government to
award a multi-million dollar contract
to a state-owned chinese company that
will supply security equipment
for 170 canadian embassies consulates
and high commissions around the world
the 6.8 million dollar contract to
supply conveyor style x-ray machines to
ramp up security
was awarded to the new tech company
which is based in beijing and
owned by the chinese government the
company is reportedly known as the
huawei of airport security supplying
technology
like state of the art x-ray machines
scanners and bomb
detection devices inside airports and
around the globe
canada's foreign affairs minister now
promising to review ottawa's purchasing
of border security equipment
and for more on the story you can go to
our website global
news dot ca slash global national
now as kovid 19 plays out the anxiety
is rising over travel a new ipsos poll
done
exclusively for global news reveals that
most canadians think
it's just far too risky to travel to the
u.s
93 percent of those surveyed feel it's
unsafe to travel to the u.s this summer
nearly just as many feel the same about
traveling overseas
more than 8 in 10 canadians or 85
percent want the canada u.s border to
stay closed until the end of the year
while just 21
want it to open to kickstart tourism
there are also fears about domestic
travel too with 62
saying it's unsafe to visit another
province
well ontario is pushing ahead with its
reopening entering
phase three of its uh recovery plan
today restaurants and bars
are open again as well as gyms and movie
theaters the rules around public
gatherings
have also been eased 50 people are now
allowed to gather indoors
and as many as 100 people can gather in
groups if they're outside
the new rules don't apply to toronto
hamilton niagara and windsor
essex near the u.s border those areas
are still trying to lower the number of
new cases
a neonatal intensive care unit at one of
british columbia's biggest
hospitals has been shut down due to an
outbreak of covid19 it is not known yet
if the cluster
inside the nicu at st paul's hospital in
vancouver is connected to
staff or newborns inside the unit
details about the number of covid19
infections have not been released
yet either but strict emergency
precautions like wearing a mask
are now in place for parents who are
visiting their babies
while there are still major concerns
about the border with the situation
in the united states still very much out
of control
the case numbers there are still rising
fast 77
000 people were infected with covert 19.
in just 24 hours yesterday
that has smashed the previous daily
record 138
000 people have died already and as
jackson prosko now reports
there are warnings that unless testing
ramps up
covert 19 will continue to run rampant
in the fight against the pandemic each
day seems worse than the one before
things are so dire that people are being
resuscitated on stretchers in the
hallways
the night before last i had four calls
of four patients dying
the number of daily infections deaths
and hospitalizations continues to grow
at a frantic pace across the u.s setting
new daily records in more and more
states
can we do better and can we turn this
around
i believe we can this will end but i
want to do it sooner rather than later
an unpublished document prepared for the
white house coronavirus task force
found 18 states are in the red zone due
to their high levels of cases and should
roll back their reopenings immediately
in one of those states georgia the
governor is now suing the mayor of
atlanta
to overturn her city's mandatory mask
requirement
i'm confident that georgians don't need
a mandate to do the right thing
i am not afraid of the city being sued
and i'll put our policies
up against anyone's any day of the week
there's so much virus circulating
researchers have warned of an impending
disaster unless the u.s
increases its testing capacity to seven
times the level being done right now
without this kind of a test we're stuck
between a rock and a hard place
either you shut down the economy and
people
have experienced significant learning
loss
or you keep things open and you lose
hundreds of thousands of americans
currently it can take up to two weeks
for results despite
warnings that a delay of more than three
days can make it
impossible to trace contacts to stop
kovid 19 from spreading further
jackson proskow global news washington
well japan has seen a spike in cases of
kovitt
reporting its highest number of
infections in three months
most of the cases are in tokyo where
more than 70 percent
of those infected are in their 20s and
30s
officials say an increase in testing
could be behind the surge in cases
and from today people without symptoms
can also get tested
the increase in cases comes a week
before the olympics were first scheduled
to start
they're now slated to begin on july 23rd
of next year
the number of confirmed cases of covet
19 around the world
is quickly nearing 14 million the death
toll now standing at at least
590 000. india now reporting
it's topped over a million cases that is
the third highest number behind the us
and brazil as redmond shannon now
reports
other countries like spain are also now
dealing with numbers that are going up
instead of down
on friday india joined the united states
and brazil
in reaching more than 1 million covet 19
cases 1.3 billion people
live in the subcontinent so the overall
infection rate
is relatively low but it is rising
fast and could be much higher especially
in rural areas
as the number were much more in the
previous months
now the number of indoor hospitalized
patients
is decreasing in delhi but in the other
part of the country the number is
increasing
india lifted its national lockdown in
june since then the virus has
spiked in some states with local
lockdowns now in place
the country also struggles with an issue
seen across
much of the world i see so many people
without mars and i'm like why
why don't they want to wear any masks
one apparent positive is that the death
rate in india
is much lower than in other countries
but experts are not sure why
in spain authorities are also imposing
local lockdown measures
the country has reported its highest
daily infection rate for
two months in london british prime
minister boris johnson announced plans
to further ease restrictions
instead of government telling people to
work from home
we're going to give employers more
discretion and ask
them to make decisions about how their
staff can work
safely brazil reached 2 million
infections this week
but the world health organization says
the curve is
leveling off there's an opportunity here
now for brazil
to push the disease down to suppress the
transmission of the virus
to take control the power to take
control is in the hands of president
jair bolsonaro
he has yet to recover from contracting
the virus but continues to insist the
economy
is more important than controlling its
spread redmond shannon global news
london and the united nations has
launched its biggest
fundraising appeal in history asking for
nearly 14 billion dollars
to help fight this pandemic the un says
the number of people needing aid has
more than
doubled since the start of this year
they now need to reach 250 million
people in 63 countries
the money will cover basic health
services and things like food water
sanitation and shelter the u.n
estimating up to 265 million people
could be facing starvation by the end of
the year due to the
impacts of covert 19 it is the third
time the organization has appealed for
financial help
since the pandemic started so far it has
received
just over two billion dollars
where is martech marta carpentier coming
up the fresh focus in the hunt
for a quebec father turned fugitive plus
a powerful storm when mother nature
faces off with edmonton's hockey arena
it was a powerful summer storm rolling
across
edmonton last night several streets
quickly flooded
causing problems for drivers rogers
place home of the edmonton oilers
also got hit with water damage the arena
is set to host
several nhl games when the season
resumes later this year
euler's entertainment group says it's
confident the damage won't delay the
start of the hockey season
toronto also dealing with extreme
weather a heat warning
is in place across the city people have
been flocking to local beaches
and patios to soak up the sun
temperatures expected to reach at least
31 degrees celsius today but with the
humidity
it could feel as hot as 42.
in other news the quebec man suspected
of killing his two daughters
is still on the run police have been
looking for marta carpentier for nine
days
now new evidence is prompting
investigators to change their tactics
our mike armstrong is at the command
center tonight with the latest mike
well sonia after a couple of quieter
days there was a considerable
ramping up today
there seems to be more of everything
more officers more canine teams more
searchers on atvs
even wildlife protection officers have
joined the search
the focus right now is on checking
structures police say they found
evidence in an rv in the area
that showed marte capacity spent time in
it
and took some items that would help him
survive anyone with any sort of a cabin
or trailer
or anything is being asked to check if
anyone's been inside
just to give you an idea of the terrain
there are a lot of forested areas but
this isn't wilderness there are
cottages and cabins all over a lot of
places to hide
but the search does seem to be focused
in the same area
where caprente's daughter's bodies were
found last
saturday six-year-old romi and 11 year
old nara
this is a community on edge tonight
they've now had a fugitive on the loose
for more than a week
a crisis center has been set up to help
people who might be having trouble
coping even the local mayor says he
wouldn't normally lock his door if he's
at home
he's now changed that habit sonia thanks
very much for that mike mike armstrong
in quebec tonight return plan
demand still ahead parents pushing for
answers to
back to school questions
it's an exciting time at the toronto zoo
with the birth of two healthy red pandas
keepers are now using video cameras to
track how they're doing
the zoo is also cautiously optimistic
about the cubs surviving
red pandas are an endangered species
it's estimated there are between
2500 and 10 000 of them left in the wild
this is the first red panda pregnancy
at the zoo in more than 20 years no word
yet
on names now normally at this point in
the summer parents teachers and students
are starting to prepare for the new
school year but back to school shopping
and lesson planning have been put on
hold because of the pandemic
most provinces and territories are
hoping to have kids back in class
in september exactly what that will look
like remains to be seen
and as jesse thomas explains parents
want ounces now
amy hill tends to her vegetable crop she
and her husband david run snowy river
farms
in cooksbrook nova scotia they
understood the decision to shut down
schools back in march
when the covet 19 pandemic emerged but
the at-home learning experience wasn't
easy
issues with shoddy rural internet made
it next to impossible to follow
curriculum
we ended up having to just say you know
what school's done for the year and
you're just going to learn
you know i'll just do math and and
spelling and different things while
we're harvesting
counting zucchinis worked then but to
manage the farm hill had to hire a
caregiver
and at five hundred dollars a week it's
something she can't afford much longer
and like many parents she's wondering
what's in store for september
and back to school we need a plan we
just need to know
you know what what are you looking to
put forward what is school going to look
like
the anxiety over a lack of plan is
shared among parents across nova scotia
a letter and petition has been sent to
premier stephen mcneil
demanding an education plan be released
immediately
to allow families to prepare i think the
challenge right now
is that there's so much speculation
because we haven't had any direct
communication from the department of
education in nova scotia
while governments work on a return to
school plan epidemiologists tracking the
novel coronavirus
say a safe return to the classroom in
canada is possible during the pandemic
but will require some significant
financial investments
we need money to hire more teachers in
order to have
smaller class sizes we need money to
equip all the staff and all students
with mass and face shields
we need money perhaps to build
plexiglass barriers between between
deaths
the pandemic has revealed the essential
role schools serve both families and the
economy
with parents expected to return to work
they need a safe place for their
children
nova scotia's education minister zach
churchill said thursday
that students will return to class
full-time in the fall
he didn't give any more details the
province will make that announcement
next week
jesse thomas global news halifax
well from nuptials to knighting next the
jubilations that brought the queen out
of isolation
well the queen's granddaughter princess
beatrice has tied the knot in a private
secret ceremony
in windsor the original date for her
wedding with eduardo mapelli mozzie was
supposed to be in may but was postponed
due to the pandemic the small gathering
included her parents
prince andrew and sarah ferguson as well
as the queen
and prince philip it's the first time
her majesty in the duke of edinburgh
stepped out of windsor castle
since going into lockdown we'll have to
wait to see the photos
though the newlyweds didn't want to
overshadow the next big event that was
on the royal agenda
the queen has knighted captain tom moore
the veteran raised millions for
charities during the pandemic
and now had a day that was priceless
crystal gomezing reports
[Music]
accolades are nothing new for captain
sir tom
moore but this this is something special
i'm absolutely overruled by the fact
that this is such a
high award that says it gets and from
her majesty as well
what more can anyone wish for than that
that has
been absolutely magnificent day for me
events at windsor castle are spectacular
but during the pandemic
there's been next to no activity the
queen has been self-isolating but
an exception was made to honor the 100
year old veteran
in person
[Music]
after all he is considered a national
treasure
he served as an officer in the british
army during the second world war
and again during the pandemic as an
inspiration
walking the length of his garden he
raised more than 50 million dollars
canadian for the uk's national health
service
he was made an honorary colonel at the
army foundation
college and performed on a chart-topping
remake
of you'll never walk alone
getting ready to meet the queen and have
the sword of
king george the sixth touch him just for
a brief moment
sent everyone buzzing do you think
she'll ask you lots of questions
it could be
cameras were kept at a distance but the
two chatted a while
i never never ever did i imagine that i
should get so close to the queen
and have such a kind message from her
that was really
outstanding it really was truly
outstanding
outstanding for him and his family her
majesty making time to engage with each
one of them
another highlight in a long life of
service
crystal gamson global news london
and that is global national for this
friday i'm sonia diol tonight's your
canada
is a view of the north saskatchewan
river in edmonton
thank you so much for watching have a
great weekend
[Music]
you